MARK DOUGLAS: So we
want to start off
by just-- I know
you play Smokey.
Diana, amazing.
If you all could just go
through and give us your names
and who you play.
I know for some of you
it's a lot of people.
DONALD WEBBER: My
name's Donald Webber.
I play a bunch of people.
I play Mickey Stevenson, who's
a big A&R guy for Motown,
and one of the
Temptations, Paul Williams.
I also play Doctor
Martin Luther King.
And I cover Stevie Wonder.
And I also am on
sometimes for Berry Gordy.
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK: Here's
the Meryl Streep of our show.
I'm Bryan Terrell Clark,
and I play Marvin Gaye.
ALLISON SEMMES: My
name is Allison Semmes,
and I play Florence
Ballard in the Supremes.
I'm also random ensemble like
a protester and a Solid Gold
Dancer.
And then I'll be playing Diana
Ross on the national tour.
[APPLAUSE]
JAWAN JACKSON: Hello,
I'm Jawan Jackson
and I play Melvin Franklin
in The Temptations.
Also I'm one of The
Miracles in Smokey Robinson
and The Miracles.
And I also am one of
the Brick House singers.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARL BROWN: My
name is Charl Brown,
and I play Smokey Robinson.
KRISHA MARCANO: Hi, my
name is Krisha Marcano,
and I cover all the
women, except Diana Ross.
So I'm all the women.
MARK DOUGLAS: You
don't cover me, girl.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN:
And that's what?
20 women?
KRISHA MARCANO: 12.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: 12 tracks.
OK, that's a lot.
I'm Krystal Joy Brown
and I play Diana Ross.
JARED NEWS: And I'm Jared News.
I'm also one of the
male swings of the show.
So I cover 25 different
tracks in the show,
including Smokey
Robinson and Marvin Gaye.
And I'm also going
to be playing Marvin
Gaye on the new national tour.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK DOUGLAS: So
let's start generally.
As we said, the show last
night was incredible.
It looks like a ton of fun.
I've never seen
people in the audience
having that much fun in a show.
You guys look like
you're having a blast.
It's a big cast.
Is it as fun as it looks?
CHARL BROWN: Yes.
TODD WOMACK: Be honest.
MODERATOR: (SARCASM) No.
CHARL BROWN: No, it really is.
I mean, listen.
We've all done a lot of shows
and done a lot of theatre.
And you get upset
at yourself when
you find yourself humming
the tunes at home usually.
But with this show, when you're
singing the songs at home,
you're actually happy.
You're like, yeah I'm
gonna keep singing it.
I don't care.
I love this music.
Also hi-jinks and
hilarity that happens
backstage is what
keeps us really going.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Or onstage.
CHARL BROWN: Or onstage.
Shh don't tell.
Our stage manager is here.
Yeah we have a lot
of fun as a cast.
We're actually a
really big family.
We feel like we are the next
generation of the Motown
legacy.
TODD WOMACK: I saw you guys do
something really funny onstage.
Somebody's wig was just a little
bit-- the piece was coming off.
CHARL BROWN: I saw
that last night.
TODD WOMACK: And you
guys were doing a scene.
And you're all doing
your lines and stuff.
MARK DOUGLAS: It was
just a nice little--
CHARL BROWN: We try and help
each other out, when we can.
MARK DOUGLAS: But it felt real.
It felt natural.
It didn't feel like--
DONALD WEBBER: They definitely
did that in the '60s.
MARK DOUGLAS: Of course, yeah.
Yeah the wig budget for this
show must have been huge.
CHARL BROWN: We have 150 wigs
that appear onstage nightly.
In the building, with all
the swings and everything,
we have over 300, around
350 wigs all together.
And our wig department--
props to them--
they have to actually restyle
the wigs before every show.
We do eight shows a week.
They have to make sure
that they're maintained.
They have to refit
them on people
if they're coming into the show.
So there's a lot of work that
goes into the wigs alone.
MARK DOUGLAS: Are they the
busiest people on the show?
CHARL BROWN: They are.
Costumes is very busy, too.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN:
Costumes and dressers, too.
MARK DOUGLAS: Have there
ever been any wig mishaps?
Like you've got
come out, oh my god!
I'm '70s Smokey!
[LAUGHTER]
In the '60s!
JARED NEWS: It happens
in Swing-Land a lot
because we have to go
on for different people
at the drop of a hat.
Someone can call out at
the beginning of a show,
midway during a show.
So the customer department has
to go down into the basement
to get your costumes
and your wigs.
And sometimes you may
have a different wig
on than is correct
for That period.
Also we forgot someone.
Alvin Huff, Jr. Alvin
over there on the keys.
MARK DOUGLAS: Let's get
you a mic, here's a stool.
ALVIN HUFF JR: Thank you, Jared.
I'm Alvin Huff, I'm one of the
keyboard players in the pit
every night.
I'm also one of the
now four conductors--
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Stand up.
MARK DOUGLAS: Were you
conducting last night?
ALVIN HUFF JR: Well I was
not conducting last night--
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN:
Isn't he handsome?
ALVIN HUFF JR: But I was
playing keyboard for you
down in the pit.
So all those good things you
heard on the piano were me.
MARK DOUGLAS: I didn't
hear any wrong notes.
ALVIN HUFF JR: Good.
CHARL BROWN: The one
thing about Alvin
that we love, too,
when he's conducting,
is he actually is acting
down there in the pit.
He has reactions to
what's going on onstage.
So it's great to have him
down there connecting.
TODD WOMACK: So
last night, we were
watching the musical director.
Is that what he's called?
MARK DOUGLAS: The conductor?
Yeah, I don't know.
That guy was having a blast.
He was bopping along to
every single song for what?
A two-hour show?
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Two
hours and 45 minutes.
TODD WOMACK: He's working
harder than you guys.
Is that every night?
CHARL BROWN: Yeah.
I mean, look.
The music is infectious.
And so, if you're in
charge of the music,
it's really infectious
and you have
to be grooving along with
it and staying in the groove
that we're setting.
MARK DOUGLAS: So
let's get into some--
TODD WOMACK: Let's
get back, yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: Let's
really start now.
So I've seen some pictures of
Smokey Robinson, Berry Gordy,
Diana Ross showing up
to the actual show.
Do they do that a lot?
How many of you have performed
the person to the person?
CHARL BROWN: Well, I
will take this one.
Smokey Robinson was just
at our show on Wednesday.
It was his birthday, and
he came he decided to come.
He comes to New York every
year for his birthday.
But this year, he
decided to come
to see the show with his wife.
It's also her birthday as well.
And they came to the show.
We knew they were
there beforehand.
And we had cake with
him that was provided
our wonderful SpotCo
team that's back there.
And we had a party for him
backstage after the show.
So for me it's always
a little nerve-wracking
to know that he's there.
Luckily though, he's been
there a few times now,
so it wasn't as nerve-wracking
as the first time.
But they all came opening night.
Diana Ross, Smokey Robinson,
Stevie Wonder, Gladys Knight.
I mean everyone pretty
much who was still
with us was able to be there.
MARK DOUGLAS: Were
the Pips there?
CHARL BROWN: I don't think we
had any Pips there on opening.
But we did also have a Friends
and Family Night the week
prior to opening, where a
lot of the other Miracles
and other members of groups--
The Temptations-- and family
members came as well.
So everyone who's been involved
in Motown-- who is still
with us-- has come to see
the show at some point.
MARK DOUGLAS: Wow.
TODD WOMACK: Do you have
any Diana Ross stories, KJ?
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Well
I just joined the cast
three weeks ago.
So I have not met her yet.
But I have murmurings
that she's coming.
And I asked, please
don't tell me.
Please don't tell me.
Tell me as soon as I
walk offstage because I
think I will poop myself.
Because, if you go
into my dressing room,
literally it's a shrine to
Diana Ross at this point.
She has kind of
taken over my world.
And I literally have dreams
about her most nights.
I actually did just last night.
Yeah meeting Smokey
Robinson was already crazy.
Sitting with Berry
Gordy and going over
notes from the first
day that he saw me.
And just sitting there and he's
like, OK I'll be Berry Gordy
and you be Diana Ross.
And I'm like-- what?
TODD WOMACK: He's like,
let's go to the sex scene.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: We're
doing these scenes together
and I'm like, what?
Oh my god.
And he's so nice.
But it's really amazing
to meet these legends
and also to kind of know
this is how we got our start.
This is how we knew we
could become entertainers.
These people have
created the path for us
as black entertainers to even
have a platform to stand on.
So it's not just meeting
these amazing icons.
It's kind of meeting the people
that inspired you to even
have the ability to have
this kind of a dream.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, as
far as meeting Diana Ross,
I don't think you have
anything to worry about
because you become her.
I mean we're talking about
what you do with your mouth,
when you sing like her.
TODD WOMACK: You sound
exactly like her.
MARK DOUGLAS: I don't
know how you get that.
You have that same glow
that she kind of gives off.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: I watch
a lot of YouTube of her.
Honestly, hours of
YouTube watching her.
And photos, and googling her.
But seriously just
constantly watching her.
And whenever I start
to feel like I've
become too much of this
century, or right now,
I just start to watch her again.
Because it is easy to
fall into, oh yeah,
well they laugh when I do this.
But that's not
something she would do.
So I have to really
make sure that it
stays within the period,
and how she does things,
and how she moves.
MARK DOUGLAS: She's definitely
one of the top divas.
So you've got to do it right.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Yeah.
To me, she's the first
black female megastar.
And that's just
kind of like, wow.
MARK DOUGLAS: And
Charl, you have that.
I mean you become
Smokey, as well.
And that voice that you do.
Can you give us--
CHARL BROWN: (BREATHY
VOICE) Yeah, man.
I had to become
Smokey to play Smokey.
[LAUGHTER]
It's true, though.
Like she said, we
luckily live in an age
where we can Google things,
and look them up on YouTube,
and try and research them.
Fortunately, and
unfortunately, there
wasn't a lot that was
captured of them, especially
in the black and
white era in the '60s.
But there are a few key
things that we actually
portray in our show.
So I went back and I
just did my research.
I also read his autobiography
just to get a sense of him.
And we also have
a great resource.
Mr. Gordy, we should mention,
wrote the show himself.
He's our book writer.
This is the story being
told from his point of view,
how he remembers things.
So we also have
him as a great tool
because he's bringing in--
he recorded everything.
All the meetings
they had, everything
it was going on at Motown.
Luckily, he recorded everything.
And his sister, Esther,
actually encouraged
him to keep things, as well.
So now they have
artifacts and things
that they wouldn't normally
think were important
because they didn't know how
big this was going to be.
So I got a chance
to listen to some
of the recordings of the
quality control meeting
that we have in the show, and
other things about the way
things were going on
behind closed doors.
Because we're telling
the full story,
not just what's in front
the cameras or on the stage.
We're telling the story of
what happened in his house.
And so we luckily have
Mr. Gordy as a resource
to actually tell
us how things were.
And Smokey is a very
nice and wonderful man
in front of the cameras, and
he is behind the stage, too.
But also they had some really
serious, heated arguments
because it was about the art
and the passion came out.
So I got a chance to
hear all the sides of it,
not just the side of a fan.
TODD WOMACK: Smokey
getting mad, like--
CHARL BROWN: Smokey getting mad.
TODD WOMACK: (BREATHY
VOICE) Hey, man.
Back off.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARL BROWN: He
definitely got mad.
MARK DOUGLAS: We're obsessed
with voices and doing voices.
Is there a struggle
to do that soft voice
and still project to a theater?
I mean you're miked, but still.
CHARL BROWN: Yeah.
Definitely, there is
a technique to it.
I mean I just had
to kind of train
myself to find where Smokey
meets Charl as the performer,
and I can do it
eight times a week,
and not hurt myself, and
be able to actually come
to work every day.
So yeah I've been doing it
now for almost a year so it's
kind of second nature to me.
But it definitely took me
awhile to develop that sound.
TODD WOMACK: I know this
is a hugely talented cast.
The impressions are outstanding.
You're doing some of the most
famous people in the world.
Stevie Wonder, Marvin
Gaye, Smokey, Diana.
Do you all do any
other impressions
that you'd like
to share with us?
CHARL BROWN: I don't.
TODD WOMACK: Nobody?
CHARL BROWN: Donald?
DONALD WEBBER: All right.
[LAUGHTER]
ALVIN HUFF JR: He's being
so modest right now.
DONALD WEBBER:
All right, listen.
I actually don't.
But I'm in improv and you
can see me at any time.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
MARK DOUGLAS: Let's
get a running start
and see what happens, right?
TODD WOMACK: We'll
come back to that one.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well I think a
lot of times in the songbook
musicals-- that would
technically be what this would
be sort of--
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Jukebox.
MARK DOUGLAS: Jukebox, songbook.
Sometimes the popular songs will
get a little too Broadway-ed
up for my tastes.
Like, every rose has its thorn.
That kind of thing.
And it sort of takes me--
TODD WOMACK: Guns N'
Roses The Musical?
MARK DOUGLAS: Well what was it?
Oh, "Rock of Ages."
But you guys did
a really good job
of sort of honoring the way
the songs were originally sung.
And it's still very
much a Broadway show.
But it didn't have that thing
that sort of can take me out
of it sometimes.
But I think sometimes
that happens
I guess to protect the voice.
It's an easier way
to sing over time.
Do you have-- no?
CHARL BROWN: Well I'll
tell you this, too.
Mr. Gordy was also very
adamant about the fact
that he didn't want to
Broadway-ize Motown.
He wanted to bring
Motown to Broadway.
And so luckily,
like I said, he was
involved so much
that they made sure
that the sound remained
authentic and true,
and that we kept the
soul of the music.
But we were telling the
story in a Broadway format.
MARK DOUGLAS: Is
that vocally taxing?
CHARL BROWN: Yes.
It is.
DONALD WEBBER: I'm going to
put the spotlight on Brian
for a second.
He sings "What's Going On?"
And I think out of all the songs
in our show, that's probably
the song that sounds the least
like it does on the record.
And it was changed
specifically for our show.
And anyway I'm just
going to kind of--
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK: I
think that the way music
functions in-- I'm
kind of like you.
Don't kill me.
I hate Broadway music.
MARK DOUGLAS: This is
your Broadway debut!
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK:
It's my Broadway debut
but it's so corny.
And it's cheesy.
MARK DOUGLAS: I
didn't want to say it.
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK:
You know what I mean.
And I mean there have been some
breakthroughs and some changes
in Broadway music, I think,
just as time and history has
changed.
The first time I heard
"Rent," I went, oh yeah!
Uh-huh.
Like that.
I like that.
But again, like you,
I couldn't stand it.
And the idea that this show was
going to be authentic to Motown
was interesting.
But it's tricky because the
way music functions in our show
is really in three
different forms.
You've got the
concert performance.
So it might look a little
bit like what you just saw.
So "Grapevine" in
the show, I mean.
Marvin's at a concert.
And then you've got
music in the studio.
We've got a "Grapevine" version
that Gladys Knight sings.
And she's recording the song.
So that's two ways
that they function
but the third is storytelling.
And that's the way that "What's
Going On?" ends Act One.
Martin Luther King is shot.
And it was a crazy
time in Detroit.
There were riots,
there were fires.
It was a violent time,
it was a scary time,
it was a heightened
emotional time.
And "What's Going On?" was
not created until after that,
in terms of the real timeline.
But it was just the perfect
song to kind of emote
and kind of tell the story of
what's happening on the stage.
And so the orchestration of
it, and the way it's sung,
and the way it's
portrayed is more
about telling the story of
what's happening in the moment
on the stage, as opposed to
it being about a performance.
If that makes sense.
So the way that the
music works in the show
is really in those
three different ways.
There's a live performance,
the studio performance,
and then there's storytelling.
MARK DOUGLAS: I really enjoyed
your Marvin Gaye moves,
by the way.
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK: Thank
you, it's all in the pelvis.
ALVIN HUFF JR: Actually,
I want to add on to that.
From the orchestral
side of things,
there's actually an
18 piece orchestra
in the pit under the
stage playing every show.
Early on, well it still
happens, but early on, I
used to get really upset
and frustrated when people
would lead over the front row.
And were like, oh my god,
there are people down there!
Were you?
Were you there the
whole-- Yes, we
were there the
whole three hours.
Yes, there are
people in 2014 that
can play music that was
written 50, 60 years ago.
Of course we can.
But everyone says, oh it sounded
so much like the recording.
And I used to be upset by that.
But now I take it as the utmost,
the highest of compliments.
Because that's what Mr.
Gordy wanted from the get-go.
He wanted it to have the
Motown sound in your face.
Not to sound like Broadway.
Not to be mixed different way.
For it to actually
sound like you're
listening to the
actual recording
that people have in their
living rooms from 50 years ago.
So I love the fact
he has remained
true to keeping that
sound every night.
And it's something
that makes coming
to do the show every
night so much fun.
I could speak for every
guy down in the pit.
We have so much fun.
Well 17 guys and one girl.
For all of us down
in the pit, we
have so much fun every night.
TODD WOMACK: Let me
tag this question
on to Brian, to
what you're saying.
This is your Broadway debut.
And your first time at Google.
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK: Yeah.
I want to live here.
TODD WOMACK: You do until
you work here all day.
[LAUGHTER]
I love it here, if
my boss is here.
But out of all the
shows out there,
I want to just propose
this to everybody here.
Start with Brian.
Out of all the
shows, I would think,
as a performer-- Like many,
people I love this music.
I love Motown music.
It looks like you
guys do, as well.
It's clear as day.
Was this a little extra
special, getting this show?
Can you tell us about
the audition process?
Maybe getting the
call that you got it?
If it doesn't endanger--
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK:
You asked the right one.
It was really hard.
We did workshops
about two years,
I think it started about
2 and 1/2 years before.
They had a reading in LA which
is almost three years before.
But I kind of came
into the process
when they were still
developing the show.
So I was a Temptation.
I was shoo doo-wop
popping in the back.
And it was great and I loved it.
I'm in the pictures still.
If you look really close, I'm
still there's as a Temptation.
But I had my eyes
on Marvin Gaye.
I mean he was my favorite
of the Motown artists.
And I got an opportunity to
audition for the workshop.
And I got it.
And for three weeks I was
kind of like obsessed,
the same way KJ was
with Marvin Gaye.
Well I was obsessed before that,
but you know for that time.
And then we finish the
workshop, and we found out
we're going to Broadway.
And they were like, we're
going to go and audition
everyone else in
the country but you.
We like what you did,
but we don't know.
You're kind of perfect but
we don't-- you're good,
but we're going to look.
And the way you feel when
you have to pee really bad?
I kind of felt that
way for months.
Did you go to the [INAUDIBLE]?
I didn't.
There was nobody to go to.
Because I was just waiting.
I mean if you've ever had
that dream job, that one thing
that you've just always wanted,
and someone says to you,
Almost but not yet.
Fast forward.
The first rehearsal of
the Broadway production
was going to begin on a Monday.
It is now Thursday.
They said, oh we're going
to do promotion shots
and we'd like you to come
in and take these pictures.
So I go in and I'm
like, who am I playing?
Who am I dressing up?
And they go, we're
going to put you
in The Temptations' costume.
Rehearsal starts on
Monday, it's Thursday.
So they bring me to
the front and they go,
just in case you're the lead
singer of The Temptations,
we want to put you in the front.
And I went, no, I'm
going to be Marvin.
And so I did the
whole thing as Marvin.
So I'm taking pictures
as a Temptation
but I'm doing Marvin Gaye moves.
And the choreographers
are laughing.
They brought me in on Friday.
I didn't hear anything.
Friday before the Monday
that rehearsal starts,
they said, Berry Gordy wants
to see you again at 6:00
p.m. at night.
So I go in, I audition.
And at this point,
I'm almost feeling
like the pee is going
to run down my leg.
And I left there.
And I went to go see a show.
I don't really
remember what show
it was-- I know
Scarlett Johansson was
in it-- because my
brain was just in a fog.
And at intermission, I got
a call from the director
and he goes, Yeah you left
something at the audition.
He goes, can you come outside?
So I've go outside
and I'm like, he's
going to tell me I got this job.
He's going to tell me I got it.
And he's standing
there with this look
of utter disappointment
on his face.
And he's like, man, listen.
You're so close to
Marvin and it's great.
But Berry Gordy is looking for
his friend that's passed on.
He's dead, and that's what's
so hard about finding Marvin.
A lot of the other
people are alive.
Marvin is not here.
And you did your best, man.
You did your best
and you're fantastic.
And we love you.
And he's walking outside,
and it's raining.
I'm literally about to cry.
And then the producer,
Kevin McCullum,
walks around the corner
and he goes, Byron.
And I was like-- He
goes, your name's Bryan.
It's that Y in your
name that makes
me want to call you
Byron instead of Bryan.
But here is a better name.
What if I just called
you Marvin Gaye?
And I fell out on the floor.
MARK DOUGLAS: And peed the
greatest pee you've ever--
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK: And
peed the greatest pee ever.
No one could tell because
it was raining outside.
And it was one of those
moments because they lifted me
off the ground.
And right across the
street, they just
put up the marquee for "Motown."
It was lit up.
So they literally
picked me up and they
were like, that's
where you'll be.
And I just was crying
and it was a mess.
But it was the best
gift in the world
to kind of start my
Broadway run that way.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK DOUGLAS: A little messed
up that they did that to you.
A little sadistic
but still cool.
TODD WOMACK: On
the marquee, it's
like, And Byron as Marvin Gaye.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh, man.
Not to focus on
you too much here,
but there's an amazing
performance of "You're All I
Need to Get By," which is
probably one of my favorite
song of Marvin Gaye's.
There's an amazing
duet that you do
as Diana Ross with Berry Gordy.
Now did you feel kind of
jipped out of that song?
Because that's Marvin's song?
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK: Man, I
wanted to set stuff on fire.
But again, no, I
didn't feel jipped.
It goes back to the way
music functions in our show.
So it's one of
those things where
it's more of a
storytelling moment.
And it's one of
those things where
it's one of the most
powerful love songs.
I mean, to me, it's one
of my favorite love songs.
And so, it just made sense to
tell the story of this love
affair that Berry Gordy had
with Diana Ross using that song.
Even though they
didn't sing it, it just
makes sense in the moment if
you come and see the show.
But I think that what's magical
about the show, in terms
of the way music works,
is if you've ever
seen Berry Gordy really look
at Diana Ross in real life,
which we've had the privilege
to do, he is obsessed with her
and he loves her.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Even just
the way he talks about here.
It's obvious.
CHARL BROWN: His face lights up.
MARK DOUGLAS: Does he like that
shrine that you have to her?
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Well
he hasn't seen it yet.
Because I just did it.
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK:
So whatever musical
is going to support a look
in a man's eye like that?
I mean do it, man.
TODD WOMACK: We'd be remiss
to not mention, is it Brandon?
Who plays Berry Gordy?
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Yeah.
CHARL BROWN: Brandon
Victor Dixon.
TODD WOMACK: Really incredible
in that moment between you
guys.
That duet.
I don't think I've ever
anything that beautiful live.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Wow,
that's a huge compliment.
TODD WOMACK: I don't get
out of the house much.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Well, in that
case, it's an OK compliment.
MARK DOUGLAS: He just
recently regained his hearing
a few years ago.
TODD WOMACK: It was amazing.
MARK DOUGLAS: Speaking of
people who aren't here today,
the kid that plays
Michael Jackson-- there's
two of them-- we saw Prince?
His name is Prince.
Hey, he's destined
for greatness.
But how old is he?
CAST: 12.
MARK DOUGLAS: And he played
Michael Jackson like to a T.
It was incredible.
Is he at school right
now or something?
DONALD WEBBER: They
have school every day.
They're actually at the theater.
CHARL BROWN: It's backstage
for them at the theater.
Everyday, yes.
MARK DOUGLAS: How-- What
were you going to say?
TODD WOMACK: The same thing
you were going to say.
MARK DOUGLAS: Have you had
to replace a Michael yet?
Because at that age, one
day you turn six feet tall.
CHARL BROWN: We still
have two, like you said.
One of them, Raymond Luke
Jr, has been in the show
from the beginning.
He's actually the
one on the posters.
Besides him, we've now had
three other Michael Jacksons,
I believe.
Prince is the third of those.
Our first one, Jibreel,
just got too tall
and his voice started dropping.
JAWAN JACKSON: (DEEP VOICE)
He was talking like this.
CHARL BROWN: We had Darius,
and now we have Prince.
Puberty hits.
MARK DOUGLAS: That's gotta be
a constant struggle to find--
CHARL BROWN: But I
keep telling Jibreel
he's going to go back as Smokey.
So it's fine.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah,
he was amazing.
He was so good.
Where am I?
Well speaking of
Michael Jackson,
the show starts and ends with
the Motown 25th Anniversary
Concert.
And I'm old enough that I
remember sitting and watching
that.
It was in 1983.
Sitting, watching that, and
it was incredible concert.
But the most amazing
part of it was
when suddenly Michael
Jackson shows up
and does a magic trick for
every one and shows the world
the Moonwalk.
No one had ever
seen the Moonwalk.
He gets up and does it.
And as an audience member,
I was like, is he gonna?
Is he gonna come out?
And then, did they
ever toy around
with maybe putting that in?
CHARL BROWN: We
did have a version
in the workshop we did a
couple years ago, where
we did have one of
our cast members--
I think it was Ephraim at the
time-- who did the Moonwalk.
He was able to do the Moonwalk.
We're not actually sure as to
why that was cut from the show.
That's not in our lane, so--
MARK DOUGLAS: It really is not
a Motown-- it's not on Motown.
BRYAN TERRELL
CLARK: I think it's
that we just have so
much music to cover.
I mean the show is two
hours and 45 minutes long.
I think the first reading
was something like six hours.
Once it was kind of
in workshop form,
it was like three
and a half, four.
And then, it was almost four.
And then in previews, we
were at a little over three.
Three, fifteen.
And so we needed to cut-- I
mean it's a great thing to say,
what a legacy Motown has in that
it's got so much music that you
can't fit it into a show.
But somebody's
going to be upset.
CHARL BROWN: We're inevitably
going to disappoint somebody.
There are things
that have been cut.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: But I
will say I have definitely
heard that there have been
murmurings of potentially
trying to put that
Moonwalk moment back
into the end of the show.
Mr. Gordy is always coming
back and adding things,
changing lines.
Only a week ago he
added the "I Wish"
ending, because he
was like, I think
audience wants to
get up and dance.
TODD WOMACK: That
was incredible.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN:
That just got added.
Like a week and a half ago.
MARK DOUGLAS: We have a
question from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
My name is Jessica, I
work here at Google.
I'm a huge Motown fan and
I've seen the show two times.
It's fun to see you guys not
in costume and as yourselves.
But my question was, I know that
so many of the characters you
play-- being such
a big fan-- have
such interesting back-stories.
And like Paul Williams
battling alcoholism
and Marvin Gaye being
murdered by his dad.
How do you take those things
that you knew, at the time
you're playing, are going
to eventually happen
to your characters?
And how do you bring
them into your acting
and how you portray
them at a younger age?
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK: I
mean it's interesting
how art imitates life,
life imitates art.
But speaking specifically
to Marvin Gaye,
who was murdered by
his dad with a gun.
Again, I was obsessed with
studying it and studying it.
And so it was kind
of all up here.
And I was acting it.
I even would honestly say
from a place that was up here.
But the first week
of rehearsal, I
got a phone call that my
cousin was shot and murdered
in Baltimore.
He was hanging out with some
friends and his phone died.
So he went out to
the car to charge it.
And his friends heard
gunshots, and ran outside,
and he was just
laying on the ground.
Dead.
And so, in a strange
way, everything
that we were singing
about-- "What's Going On?"
Dr. King being shot-- it
all just got a lot closer.
And it kind of moved
from a cerebral
placed to kind of a gut place.
And so it became a lot
easier because every time
I sang "What's Going On?"
it moved from that place.
But then a lot of things in
the country, just like Motown,
began to happen.
We had the whole Trayvon
Martin situation that happened.
And we found out the verdict
of Trayvon Martin right
before we sang
"What's Going On?"
And it was a magical,
amazing, tragic moment onstage
when we sing this song.
And I kind of just turned to
my right and turned to my left,
and the whole entire stage
is sobbing singing this song.
And so it's one of
those things where
I think we're kind
of experiencing
a little bit of what
Motown experienced.
We're out there
to sing and dance.
We want to make
people feel good.
And we want to make people leave
with the love of music the way
we have it ourselves
as performers.
But there's some stuff
that's going on in the world.
And so when that begins
to affect the music,
you can feel it change.
And that's what
happened with Motown.
I think they really
kind of started off
in this entertainment,
song-and-dance place.
And as the civil rights
movement began to develop,
and we had everything going on
in Europe and the Vietnam War,
as time progressed, you can
hear it change in the music.
So we've been
experiencing that even
as a cast just
over the last year.
CHARL BROWN: So we've come
a long way from the '60s,
and we're still in the
same places sometimes, too.
We're still in the middle of the
civil rights movement, as well.
So there's a lot
of things that we
can address in the
show that are still
going on in our everyday lives,
as well, that we can bring
to the stage.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: And
I'll just say that,
as some of these
characters start from-- I
know Diana Ross starts from 17
and goes to her mid '30s, '40s.
And I think just kind of
playing in the moment what
the ambition, what the
motive is at that moment.
OK, just to get a record deal.
And then it's like,
get closer to him.
And then it's be a star onstage.
And then, oh god.
And playing every
moment as it comes.
That kind of helps to pace the
journey and the arc of what
everyone's going through.
Because there is so much.
Your motives do change
as the music changes,
as Motown changes.
And as everyone
grows, you kind of
try to stay in tune with
that, as far as like your age,
and what your ambition is,
or what their ambition was.
It helps reading
their autobiographies
or getting to talk to them,
and seeing chronologically
what they were mentally
going through at that time
and then kind of trying
to get where they were.
ALLISON SEMMES: I
play Florence Ballard.
And her life was kind of tragic.
She started off in the Supremes.
And then she was kicked out.
And then she was suffering from
all sorts of mental illnesses
and alcoholism.
And so I think it's
all about balance,
how Mr. Gordy wanted
to nod his head to it.
But he didn't want to
disrespect her in any way.
There's one scene where I leave
in the middle of the song,
or at the end of the song
I just kind of walk off.
And Shelley, who is one of
our associate directors,
was saying how she didn't want
me to stumble off, just kind
of hint at it and still
have some type of dignity.
But then at the same time,
mentally as the character,
I'm going through
that with each song.
I'm excited in beginning
as the Primettes.
And then, as we get
through the songs,
I become less and
less excited about it.
And finally, at the
end, there's this point
where my actor mind
has made up that I'm
done with being a part of it.
And so it's a balance of being
true to the story but then,
at the same time, knowing
what they went through.
AUDIENCE: Well you guys
do it very, very well.
CHARL BROWN: Thank you.
JAWAN JACKSON: I
also want to say
the thing with me and Donald.
As a Temptation
at the Motown 25,
we're kind of aging backwards.
So we're old.
AUDIENCE: There are
so many Temptations.
JAWAN JACKSON: Right.
The Temptations
and the Four Tops.
And so, at that
point in our lives,
our career is
almost on the cusp.
We're trying to reintroduce
ourselves to the world.
And that was our moment where
we get to show we still have it.
And so it's kind of
like the motivation of,
we have to re-prove ourselves
to these people and the world
that we still have
it, and we can still
go out there and sing, though
we're slower in little older.
And then as the show progresses,
you see the younger Temptations
and they have more life.
And they haven't been going
through the situations,
the alcoholism parts,
and things like that.
But it's a mind
thing where we have
to remain conscious of what
these people went through.
And Melvin Franklin
in particular
was going through all
kinds of health issues.
And, after shows
he would have to go
and his feet were
bloody because he
has blisters and all
kinds of ailments.
And I feel like,
in the show, that I
took on some of those ailments
because I feel like my knees
and-- It took me out.
Literally.
I kind of like
subconsciously go into that.
And I'm like, no, lord.
I'm 26, I'm not 56.
Let me get it together.
MARK DOUGLAS: It's
amazing to see
how young you guys
are in person.
I swear to God, by
the end of the show
I have these images of you
guys as being kind of run-down.
But I'm like, oh these
guys are younger than me.
They look great.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Run-down?
MARK DOUGLAS: No.
Except for you.
Diana?
Never.
TODD WOMACK: Talking
about connecting reality
to the characters, KJ,
here's a question for you.
There's a moment in the show
where you, as Diana Ross,
come out and sing "Reach Out
and Touch Somebody's Hands."
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Just
"Reach Out and Touch."
TODD WOMACK: "Reach
Out and Touch."
Sorry.
MARK DOUGLAS: The outfit you're
wearing during that part,
you've got be careful what
they reach out and touch.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Some
people get very touchy.
TODD WOMACK: That's my question.
Because you bring up somebody.
First of all, it's
after the intermission.
You come out and it's this is
great interactive moment where
that you bring the audience
back into the show.
Energy is way high.
And then you bring
somebody on stage
and have them sing
along with you.
Last night, it was two people.
It ended up being two really
different but beautiful,
touching moments.
Is it always that perfect?
Tell us the spectrum
of things that happen.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Perfect.
No, it's a broad spectrum.
You don't really know.
Sometimes I'll be like,
who wants to come up here?
And sometimes there
will be a volunteer.
Sometimes they'll be like,
please don't look at me.
People will look down.
Luckily, it can be
terrifying for some people
and I want to find
that terrified guy.
I think that they're
the sweetest.
And I'm like, come on up here.
Play with me.
And then they'll
kind of ease into it.
I feel like it makes the
audience really comfortable.
And then sometimes you get
people that are super eager
and they know that they
have a fierce voice.
And they're auditioning
to be in Motown.
And you don't know that until
they take the microphone out
of your hand and you're
like, OK and I still
have to sing this song.
Thank you very much, sit down.
MARK DOUGLAS: The guy
that you brought up
last night it
almost looks like he
could have been in the Mafia.
He was like, reach out
and touch somebody's hand,
forget about it.
[LAUGHTER]
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: I don't know.
They seem to love
it and I love it.
And it's personally one of my
favorite moments in the show.
Because I do in my own shows,
in solo shows, or whatever,
I am so in the
audience and I really
want to connect with people.
And as I've been
watching Diana Ross
and how she loved
to sing that song--
she really loved to go
out into the audience
and sit on their
laps and kiss people.
And she was very personable.
And I think that's such a
good representation of her
and the kind of performer
that she wanted to be.
MARK DOUGLAS: Was that
something that she
would do that literal
part of the song?
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN:
She would literally
go out in the audience,
go out to your table,
or go into the audience.
Sit on your lap.
Talk to you.
It was typically
about a 10 or 15
minute moment in her concerts.
She would, at the end, have
everyone raise their arms,
and sway, and sing.
That was her standard
thing in the '70s and '80s.
It was a big part of her gig.
TODD WOMACK: Thank you
Do we have any more
questions from the smart,
beautiful people in here?
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Don't be shy.
TODD WOMACK: Just
approach the microphone
because they are recording it.
And I'll fill it with
some filler music.
AUDIENCE: Would you like
to sing another song?
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN:
We have to think
about 30 something,
40 songs tonight.
So why don't you come
and see the show?
[LAUGHTER]
MARK DOUGLAS: You
really should see it.
It really is incredible.
We were talking about the
pressure of not only performing
for some of the people that
are still alive that you're
actually playing, but
when I was coming back
to sit down in my seat,
I heard an old guy
like talking to the usher.
He was like, I saw the Supremes
in 1957 in Oakland, California.
And then in 1958, I
saw them in Washington.
And the guys is like,
uh-huh, OK, great.
But then I started
looking around
and it sort of
seemed like there's
a lot of that type of
person in the audience that
have lived through this.
And you're kind of representing
their youth in a way.
Is there a lot of pressure
to kind of live up
to people's memories?
CHARL BROWN: I think we feel
the responsibility to uphold
their memories.
And our thing is, like it
says at the Motown Museum,
live it again.
For a lot of people,
they're coming out.
For a lot of people
actually, we've
experienced that this is
their first Broadway show.
So not only are they getting
to relive their youth,
but they're also
being introduced
to the theater, which is
something that I personally
love about our show.
That people who would not have
normally come to the theater
are.
But also, I just think
we feel the importance
of the legacy of
Motown that we try
to do our best to represent
these people so that we can
uphold the things
that they remember.
So they don't walk
away being like,
well that wasn't really-- They
stand at the stage door nightly
and thank us for our portrayals
of the people they love.
And they're like, you
were just like Smokey.
And that means a
lot to me actually
when they do that, because
that's what we're up here.
That's why we're doing it.
As an artist, that's
what you strive to do,
is to make people happy.
DONALD WEBBER:
Something that's really
cool to me is, you
look into the audience
and you see someone who's 80
sitting next to someone who's
50 who's sitting next to
someone who's 20 who's
sitting next to
someone who's 10.
I remember growing up
listening to this music.
I'm 27.
My mother listened
to this music.
Her mother listened
And so it's such a
big responsibility
to be able to kind of
pass it on in this form.
And on Broadway.
TODD WOMACK: You're not thrown
off by people singing along?
I swear, the lady
two rows behind me
was singing all the
parts to "My Girl."
She was going, my
girl, my girl, my girl.
All the parts.
I looked back at some point,
because we were fairly
near the front.
And every fourth person
is singing along.
CHARL BROWN: There's
a moment in the show
that I have to mention.
When I'm singing "You Really
Got a Hold on Me," uh-oh.
MARK DOUGLAS: Sing
it, Charl, sing it.
CHARL BROWN: (SINGS)
But I love you.
There you go, baby.
That was for you.
MARK DOUGLAS: Tony
nominee Charl Brown.
CHARL BROWN: So
we're doing that.
It's a very tense moment.
We're in the South
and it's the '60s.
And you know what was going
on in America in the South
in the '60s.
It was very racially
charged and we're
trying to have a
dramatic moment.
I start the song very timidly.
I'll do it again for you.
(SINGS) I don't like you.
And then I pause.
And then I'm going to
pick back up later.
Meanwhile the audience,
depending on who they are,
has going onto the chorus.
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK: And
they're good and happy, too?
CHARL BROWN: They're like--
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK: (SINGS
LOUDLY) But I love you.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARL BROWN: And they're like,
you really got a hold on me.
I'm like--
(SINGS) But I love you.
This is my gig.
They're paying me.
No, but we do have some people
who are very responsive.
But actually it's
all in good fun.
I do love it.
It's fun to have to
take back control
of the audience in that way.
But a lot of
people, like I said,
it's their first
time on Broadway.
They come to have a concert
and have a good time.
The ushers constantly have
to ask them to sit and remain
in their seats so the
people behind them can see.
We do have a
standing room section
if you want to come and stand.
So it's a fun time,
and we love being
a part of that for people.
ALLISON SEMMES: That's the
thrill of live theater.
It's not a movie where
there's a screen.
But when the audience is
involved, it's like, yes,
we're all in it together.
And it kind of just
puts down the wall.
MARK DOUGLAS: It makes
it new again for you.
JAWAN JACKSON: I had
a person my first
like the first
month of previews.
She would stand outside every
day, everywhere we went.
Melvin, Melvin!
And I'm like, who?
You!
Oh my god, I love you!
Literally everywhere I went.
I would go to the grocery
store, Good Morning America.
She'd just scream my
name and would stand out,
just scream my name, and
ask me to hug her and take
a picture every time.
These people are
invested in this show.
And they really think
that we are these people
that we portray.
I'm like, I'm Jawan.
[LAUGHTER]
TODD WOMACK: No, you're Melvin!
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: I just want
piggyback on the responsibility
the show and the connections.
Last night, I went out the stage
door at the end of the show.
And I met these two
women from the South,
and they were like 70 and 71.
And they were talking
about how they
were school teachers
in the '60s,
and how they would see the
first black-- she's like,
I had the first black
child in my class.
And I just know
how tense it was.
I'm so glad you
guys really talked
about how tense
it was down there.
Because she was
from South Carolina.
That is a real thing and we
would listen to this music.
And it really
brought down walls.
It really opened up-- She
was like, I went to a concert
for Marvin Gaye.
And it was the first
time I had ever
seen black women and
white women screaming
for the same person at the
same time in the same building.
I was like, Oh my.
It just reminds you
how real this is.
Being young and
not really having
lived that kind of segregation?
You're kind of like, holy--
when someone can come up to you
and tell you and cry
to you about seeing
that first black child who
was terrified in the room.
She's just like how do I
make this child feel better?
No one needs to feel like this.
And for her to relive that.
And also get relieved that
this is where we are now
by watching the show, it
just touched me so deeply.
I stood there and talked to
them for like 30 minutes,
because it just felt so good
to hear how this moved them
and how remind
them of a time that
was so vulnerable for
the entire country.
MARK DOUGLAS: That's
great that you
get to see it happen
every night, you know?
Everybody is brought together
by this music before your eyes
every night.
It must be a great feeling.
TODD WOMACK: Yeah.
We have about four
minutes left but I just
want to ask you guys
about the end of the show.
Having been a performer and
stuff, seeing tons of Broadway
shows.
I have never seen anything
like the end of the show.
Everyone in the audience
is on their feet clapping.
And you don't make them.
Everybody's just giving
a standing ovation
in the big concert part.
MARK DOUGLAS: You
feel like something's
about to start, not end.
TODD WOMACK: I mean it
was late on a work day.
You've got older
people in the audience.
That place is thriving.
On their feet.
So much fun.
The show ends and people are
like, all right let's go!
There's so much energy.
MARK DOUGLAS:
Let's start a band.
TODD WOMACK: Is it
like that every night?
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Every
day, matinees, every day.
It's shocking.
It's amazing to see because you
aren't always a part of shows
that do that.
That's what I love
about the show,
that people are going to leave.
And no matter what is going on
their life, even from the cast,
I think it's a moment where
you just kind of check out.
And you feel really good.
It just kind of motivates
you to be happy.
There's something really
joyous about this show.
And Mr. Gordy and
Charles Randolph-Wright,
my mom's fiance had passed
away the day before I started.
And so they were supposed
to come that weekend.
And she decided to come
the following week.
And they were like,
have her come.
Charles said that Trayvon
Martin's mom came twice.
She had to come twice because
it just made her feel better.
She was like, this
is the first time
I've really smiled and laughed
since my son was killed.
And so it's amazing to me
how it does transform you.
And even going
through that myself,
and losing someone-- and
lots of people in this past
have had a lot of personal
drama-- but for some reason,
that building and this show
has such power to uplift.
And I think that
is transcendent.
And we watch it every
single day as the audience
stands up, and is
screaming, and clapping,
and just wants to
have a joyous moment.
And I've never seen that.
This is my fourth Broadway show
and I've never seen it happen.
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK:
It's infectious.
I mean it really is kind
of like a sugar high.
You might think, I've
been at work all day.
The last thing I want
to do is come and sit
for 2 and 1/2 hours or
2:45 and watch a show.
And literally it's like
getting a shot of adrenaline.
It's like whatever that juice
they give to Honey Boo Boo
Child.
TODD WOMACK: Go-go juice!
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK: I mean
even as performers, you come in
and you're like, woo!
We were at Google all day
and we did interviews,
and we did this.
I'm so tired.
And then that music
starts and by the end,
you're like, woohoo!
It's one of those things.
Come to the show,
it's so infections
that literally people have flown
their relatives out to see it.
We've gone outside
and people are like,
I live down the street.
I've seen this show four times
but I flew out my whole family.
I mean it really is
one of those shows.
So come and see it.
It'll literally uplift you.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN: Especially
if you're in a bad mood.
MARK DOUGLAS: It's
musical go-go juice.
BRYAN TERRELL CLARK:
It's musical go-go juice.
TODD WOMACK: We want to thank
you guys so much for your time,
and your effort,
and your dreams.
CHARL BROWN: Thank
you for having us.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN:
Yeah, it's our pleasure.
MARK DOUGLAS: Go
warm up your voice.
Drink some tea.
TODD WOMACK: Drink some tea.
MARK DOUGLAS: Get in character.
Thank you so much for coming
out and talking to us nerds.
TODD WOMACK: Yeah,
the show is amazing.
Go see it.
It's a lot of fun.
It's so much fun.
KRYSTAL JOY BROWN:
Thank you, guys.
CHARL BROWN: And
thanks for lunch, too.
That was great.
MARK DOUGLAS: Thank you so much.